hey folks it's a Eric Tay here i'm
joined by john carlo very Nene all right
hey let's go a long time yeah we're
going to talk about the new destiny dark
below preview that was kind of shown
today I'm gonna break some of it down to
kind of see what's interesting what we
think is interesting yeah so let's do it
we heard loud and clear what players
wanted they wanted more that's what
we've tried to do in the dark below just
bring bring people more yeah so I think
what's interesting about that there is
just that you know yes that is a big
complaint about destiny as it stands
just there's not enough content and
obviously this is going to bring some
content new content to the original game
which will go into depth later but is
this still even going to be enough for
people I see the thing is the content
that they've had laid out which is I
think as as you said we're going to go
into it but there's at least one you
strike for everyone to for PlayStation
owners and then there's three missions
and the rate i want to say the raids
probably not going to get unlocked to
later on so day one you're going to have
those things to do as well as the three
new multiplayer maps depends on how long
they done till the next expansion I
would I would imagine maybe like a three
month window but it's probably not
enough unless the raid takes you that
long I guess because everything else
leading up to the raid is why I gonna
take you like a couple days I not even
yeah I hope so so what's interesting
about Eris is I wonder if she actually
is a response to the story complaints
about destiny and just that there is
enough of it like on the surface and
that they wanted to build this character
as sort of a narrative device so that
people get more story elements directly
from the game itself as opposed to
reading grimoire cards and that sort of
thing I mean it has to be I would
imagine she already has so much more
that she's talking about then we've kind
of heard before just like from a preview
right she's building up what her
experience was trying to you know defeat
crota back in the day she hid this whole
time because they couldn't do it and now
she's trying to help guide you
to get revenge of special significance
there's that we saw dude using the sword
I think they figured out yeah i think
everyone likes using the sword the
question is is if only for one person
again because that's kind of a
bummed-out everyone else was you know we
would get in there with our 33 man fire
team and only one person got to wield
the sword it looks like it's going to be
a mission instead on the cosmic Jones so
maybe the lit more than one person use
it this time i don't know i mean like
obviously it's so lovable but it would
be nice to see three people running
around with the sword just chopping
stuff up so speaking about errors it's
actually interesting we just saw her
bleed from her eyes which is kind of
creepy but she has three eyes almost
pseudo like a hive the question is i
know i know she's been hiding out or she
you know she hid in the caves what do
you think is going on with a three I
thing well I mean she's also clutching
like an object that's glowing green so
it seems like she has been infused with
some kind of hive magic I guess that's
basically caused her what seems like
it's caused her to mutate sort of so
like whatever she's holding is like
radioactive and obviously her eyes are
bleeding some sort of black goo which I
wonder if that is like the darkness or
whatever that gets referenced at various
points during the game or if that's just
high blood or whatever that is but yeah
it's kind of freaky
so that part I don't really have
anything else to say other than that
looks hella sweet are we falling from
that top area all the way down to this
kind of platform area that we're at that
looks like it's pretty much almost pitch
black sands the circle that you're
standing in its Allah you know vault of
glass hold the hold the area and you
know I think maybe that bridge that you
run across that kind of slowly build out
or something after you've held this long
enough you can kind of see it in the
background in some of these shots so I
just think it's pretty cool the thralls
come after you like level 30 throws so
you were saying something interesting
about this map in particular earlier
just about I got that environment I'm up
with some other things I think visually
this was one of those locations that
looked kind of the most stunning in the
game when you're playing single player I
think it got kind of lost in the shuffle
because it was so short lived yeah I
mean I'm really happy that they're going
to the black garden with this one and I
you know after doing so much iron banner
over the last week I'm super super happy
to see some new multiplayer maps so no
matter what they do I'll just be happy
to see those in rotation and really like
the visual design of this map just that
bone area alone is another one of those
areas that was really memorable for a
lot of people just running by gonna lose
[ __ ]
so we get a glimpse of some of the new
weapons and armor pieces that will be in
the dark below presumably some of those
are raid weapons we're seeing some that
are called various things of crota I'm
going to go out on a limb and say that
they're probably red weapons mainly
because they also have what is now the
Oracle disrupter so it's probably some
hive type disrupter so I don't know what
the Oracle equivalent is for Kuroda but
clearly at least I think from from what
we've seen there's like three weapons
that i can say like probably our raid
weapons and we also get to see some of
the new exotics which we've kind of
gotten a sneak preview of before because
it's been data mined unfortunately for
destiny but uh my dragon's breath and
whatnot so now we're getting to see in
action that's kind of cool i'm looking
forward to seeing if there's any type of
a special raid weapon a lot like a fake
bringer that has like a nice double
modifier of explosion or something like
that but yeah in terms of just what
we've seen today like a lot of cool
stuff coming out you know crota i want
to kill crota yeah so that's going to be
an interesting fighting yeah I'm super
excited for this I mean even you know
with the lore kind of being where it's
at like I you know I feel like they're
making improvements in that area for
sure with Eris and that's great to see
alright well that was a quick kind of
breakdown of what we kind of saw I'm
sure there's some things you guys might
see that we didn't talk about
necessarily but if you want to talk
about go ahead and talk about it in the
comments but thank you john carlo no
thank you thank you it's been a pleasure
always is